hi tnc hi martin good to see you again
you too i want to ask your help in
answering a few more questions from me
and other developers
about pub sub ordering today of course
i'm happy to help let's get on with them
[Music]
so tnc in the last episode you
introduced ordering of pub sub messages
in the right hailing app i was building
in my original
implementation if a user requested a
ride and then
cancelled that ride sometimes the
cancellation would arrive before the
initial write request
which confused my application ah yes i
remember that
you enabled message ordering to resolve
this issue
yeah you showed me how to do that so
that all messages for a particular
writer
arrive in the order they're published in
other words
the ordering key is the writer id
here's my code for that and here's my
pub sub subscription
in the cloud console with the ordering
box checked
very nice we can refer back to your code
and your configuration as we answer the
questions
excellent so the first question is from
jacob on stack overflow specifically
about the push
subscription case jacob writes does
cloud pub sub message ordering
mean the subsequent message is not
delivered
until the previous one is acknowledged
that is correct to use an example from
the right handling app
if the request right message by bobcat
is published before the cancer write
message by bobcat
the request right message must be
acknowledged by your application
before pubsub even delivers the
canterrate message oh
so does that mean that i can create a
bottleneck if
my code doesn't acknowledge messages
that is likely for bobcat
but it won't affect other writer ids for
instance
this won't affect request and cancel
right messages from starfish
to avoid blocking subsequent messages
from individual writers
your code should always acknowledge
messages
if the message is badly formatted or if
your code
throws an exception catch that exception
acknowledge the message
and report the error to the operator
don't fail to acknowledge and order the
message
for an extended period of time so the
second question is from robin thomas
in a comment for our previous video
what's the behavior
when the publisher sets message ordering
and publishes messages with an ordering
key
and there are multiple subscribers
listening to the same topic
but only one of them is interested in
ordered messages
that is a great question i think there
are two parts to it
for serverless and push it's easy you
have only one push url
per subscription for example in your
right handling app
the subscriber is your service built in
cloud run
outside serverless however pull
subscriptions are more common
when multiple subscribers like multiple
compute
engine instances are pulling from the
same topic
messages of the same ordering key are
delivered to the same subscriber
you may hear this described as the
affinity guarantee of pub sub ordered
delivery
okay so what if i have multiple
subscribers
pulling from a subscription and only one
of them is interested in ordered
messages
subscribers actually don't control what
kind of messages they get
ordered or unordered instead this is
determined by the subscription
if the goal is to separate unordered
messages from ordered messages
it's probably best to publish them to
different topics
in a right-tiling app it would be a good
idea to publish
ordered messages like request write and
cancel right messages
to a writer's topic and unordered
messages
like when a user updates their password
to a different topic
all right so i think what this means to
me for my ride-hailing app
is that one if i use push subscriptions
and a serverless subscriber like
cloudrun i don't have to worry about
multiple subscribers and two it makes
things
easier if i publish ordered and
unordered messages to
different topics you got it
all right uh very good so now the third
question
yesterday in my right hailing app i
noticed that i got an exception
when trying to publish a message after
that
no more messages for that writer id that
ordering
key were published so how should my code
deal with publishing exceptions and and
this happened when i was
moving topics around and changing
permissions
i'm glad you asked about it because
there is something
special here most publishing failures
are retried automatically but in the
case of
non-retireable errors for example if the
topic has been deleted
and you're using ordering you shall call
resume publish
to restart publish messages of the
affected ordering keys
you can add this code to resume your
publisher in a try catch block
excellent tnc now for the fourth and
final question
my system has one cloud run service
running in europe
and another running in the us and both
publish ordered pubsub messages to the
same topic
will ordering still work yes
if you specify the same regional
endpoint
when you create the publishers you can
look up
the list of available regions here and
pick one from the list
oh so if i use this code with this
regional endpoint
all messages would be published in
europe even if this code actually runs
in the u.s
that's right great thank you tnc
i think my right hailing app will work
much better after i implemented these
tips you've shown me
well that's wonderful to hear getting
ordering right
is useful and i'm glad to help if you
have any questions for tnc or me
please leave them in the comments below
also let us know if there are other
serverless topics you'd like to see in
our videos
until next time